deux jours après le violent cambriolage
dont ils ont été victimes
marie et françois sont toujours sous le
choc tout a commencé lundi vers 13h
quand cinq hommes font irruption dans
leur ferme
il arrive une voiture donc deux hommes
par contre non cagoulés sont descendus
de voiture arrive jusqu'à la maison et
demande à mon copain pour acheter un
agneau donc mon copain leur dis attendez
je mets mes chaussettes j'arrive et de
la libye au fichu un coup sur la tête et
moi de là qu'est ce que je vois deux
hommes cagoulés qui passe sur le côté de
la fenêtre
ils ont ligoté mon ami et puis nous
avons reçu des coups de poing pl la
figure des hématomes au niveau de l'oeil
et du dos une entorse des vertèbres
cervicales
le couple d'éleveurs subi la violence
des cinq hommes cagoulés et pendant ce
temps tous les meubles sont retournés
ils sont venus essentiellement pour
l'argent et donc ils savent que lors des
fêtes de l'aïd el kébir ça génère
toujours un peu d'argent moi quand je
vends des moutons je demande toujours
des espèces par sécurité et c'est pour
ça qu'ils
ce qui nous ont agressés quoi ils
savaient très bien qu'ils envoient de
l'argent pour marié françois le calvaire
durera près d'une heure de l'argent des
bijoux des fusils et un téléphone
portable seront volés avant de fuir les
cambrioleurs renferme le couple dans les
toilettes
on est resté peut-être dix minutes 10
minutes et ensuite
ensuite moi je suis monté sur les
toilettes pour ouvrir la fenêtre pour
écouter si j'entendais le bruit de
voiture partir et quand j'ai entendu le
bruit partir chez dia françois vite il
faut qu'on sorte de là à l'heure
actuelle les agresseurs n'ont toujours
pas été identifiés le parquet d'auxerre
a ouvert une enquête pour vol avec arme
en bande organisée les auteurs encourent
jusqu'à trente ans de réclusion
criminelle